bonjour à tous
alors moi je m'appelle nicolas paciello
et je suis depuis maintenant
vingtaine d'années chef pâtissier
j'aimerais si vous me le permettez
pendant ces huit minutes qui vont
arriver
et dans mon univers
quand on me demande pourquoi j'ai fait
ça métier
j'ai toujours là
revient
l'adolescent était abl et je voyais m
arrivé avec ce marbre est sur la table a
axé ses odeurs on était tous là à y
regarder on avait juste envie de sauter
dessus et je me suis dit waouh
14 ans quand j'ai
c'est ça que je veux faire
ur et des émotions procurer des émotions
aux gens
d'ailleurs
c'est chez les grecs on retrouve le
premier
milan
ce qui signifie
de ce gâteau déjà qu'on offrait aux
dieux grecs
chez fauchon dans ce milieu qui était
déjà enfin bien lancer la pâtisserie
était bien lancée
tout ça par le travail des deux grands
chefs comme pierre hermé ou philippe
conticini
qui ont beaucoup oeuvré dans le goût et
la texture
il ya eu la génération de christophe
michalak et consorts qui nous ont eux
sortis de nos cuisines
ken groll
ma génération a donc bénéficié des deux
pour
tout ça du beau et du bon
on était dense
clairoix en fait
on était prêt à tous les sacs ce
ont travaillé des jours entière j'ai
fait ça toute ma vie d'ailleurs
deux semaines
ben quand j'étais à droite et à gauche
parce qu'on voulait tous gagnés en fait
et puis les deux hétéro je peux vous en
parler moi des dommages collatéraux
parce que
m'a coûté mon mariage en 2018 quand j'ai
voulu atteindre l'excellence en
inscrivant au concours des meilleurs
ouvriers de france
pareil une étape où j'ai bossé bossé
bossé
j'étais finaliste c'est une super
expérience
course
ce
g
de
communication qui nous a plu tout de
suite en pâtisserie
en plus puissants
alors oui la pâtisserie est devenu de
plus en plus instagram abl
oui on a gagné en notoriété
confrères
oui
fait rayonner la pâtisserie française
dans le monde entier grâce à ça mais est
ce que nos gâteaux ils sont toujours
aussi bon
quand vous venez goûter
on crée tous les jours
on met le beau et le bon au service de
l'émotion
j'imagine d'ailleurs que dans cette
certains ou instagram
chef peut-être mois
[Musique]
tous
sont bons ces gâteaux parce que je pense
pas vous laisser égoutter en fait pas
tous en tout cas
je veux dire par
bien au contraire
moi aussi pas mal de temps
et eux
je posterai table probablement 1 sur ce
sur ce moment juste incroyable j'ai
entendu dire avec vous aujourd'hui
mais juste
instagram c'est un tourbillon en tous
parce que la pâtisserie retard est un
métier artisanal quoi qui quoi qu'il en
soit ça restera toujours dans ses côtés
des plus nobles un métier artisanal dans
lequel on arrive le matin et aureilhan
et on transforme des choses
mais on a vite fait de se faire happer
par des grosses marques
des collaborations pour pour but de
bénéficier de votre notoriété
peut-être
votre votre image de valeur
et à penser à fait
le client
1 quels clients
vous qui se sera déplacé en boutique qui
aura choisi santi qui aura peut-être
même discuté avec l'artisan ou bien le
conseiller de vente pour en apprendre un
peu plus
moi ce client depuis que je suis
entrepreneur
depuis que ces entrepreneurs dans le
mille dans le milieu de la pâtisserie
la première préoccupation
il ya un an et demi de ça j'ai créé ma
marque avec mon astuce et william
assouline qui lui n'était pas du milieu
mais avec qui je partage les mêmes
valeurs
quand il est venu me chercher en
décembre 2000 en décembre 2018
m'a proposé ce projet
comme les autres
en temps et j'ai accepté parce que
suis dit qu'avec cette aventure là
je vais pouvoir créer
chose est autre chose que des gâteaux en
fait
il ya très peu de temps de ça j'ai vécu
je pense un des moments les plus forts
de ma carrière
je n'évoque beaucoup j'ai vécu beaucoup
mais souhaitait vraiment fort c'est dans
la boutique et j'ai vu cette dame qui
est rentré cette dame chez qui j'étais à
les cuisiner un mois de ça avant
via une association pour laquelle je
travaille qui a pour but de ramener des
petits moments de vie à ses aînés
parfois trop confiné
donc je vois cette dame on à ce jeu de
regard et puis
je vois son sourire même à travers le
masque et elle vient me voir et elle me
dit elle mais murmure à l'oreille que
elle avait vécu ce moment mémorable chez
elle à la maison
ul
venir manger une pâtisserie chez moi
presque à la maison et qu'elle en
oublier le temps
en fait quand je fais vivre
ça
jours et c'est pour ça que je vais
continuer à me lever et aller travailler
jour après jour
parce que j'en suis persuadé intimement
convaincu que c'est en continuant à
créer ces émotions là
qu'un jour peut-être
ce serait moi aussi le roi de la jungle
[Applaudissements]